Like, concept is a concept in C++. Whoa! And, yes. There's a thing called concepts? There's a thing called concepts. Yeah, I think there's not actually that much going on currently in the reflection study group. I think the work there has kind of stalled, I think.
比如，concept 是 C++ 中的一个概念。哇！而且，是的。有个东西叫 concepts？有个东西叫 concepts。对，我觉得反射研究组目前其实没有太多进展。我觉得那里的工作有点停滞了，我觉得。
And I'll make a bolder statement. I'll be very surprised if any major language feature ships in C++. Period. be very surprised if any major language feature ships in C++, period. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 150, recorded on September 25th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about the state and future of C++ and our opinions on whether or not C++ is dying. All right, folks, episode 150. We're almost at the three-year anniversary of ADSP the podcast and I'm excited. I'm excited to record this podcast
而且我要说得更绝对一点。如果有任何重大语言特性在 C++ 中发布，我会非常惊讶。句号。如果有任何重大语言特性在 C++ 中发布，我会非常惊讶，句号。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客，第 150 期，录制于 2023 年 9 月 25 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，探讨 C++ 的现状与未来，以及我们对 C++ 是否正在消亡的看法。好了，各位，第 150 期。我们即将迎来 ADSP 播客的三周年纪念日，我非常兴奋。我很兴奋能录制这期播客
because I think it's gonna do well on the socials. I think people are gonna have a listen. Welcome to the new listeners. My name is Connor. I'm here with my co-host Bryce. We both work for NVIDIA. We are both, I don't know, I kind of consider myself not a former C++ engineer, but I work in research now and I get to code in whatever I code in. And I am a huge Python fan now. I don't really write C++ or Rust code. I write Python code that writes C++ and Rust code for me because that's way easier. And we'll talk about that in a future episode when I can talk about the projects that I'm working on. But Python is amazing. And while we were on our quote-unquote four-month break, we weren't really on a break, but we had recorded a ton of content.
因为我觉得它在社交媒体上会反响很好。我觉得大家会听的。欢迎新听众。我是康纳。我和我的联合主持人布莱斯在这里。我们都在英伟达工作。我们都是，我不知道，我其实不认为自己是前 C++ 工程师，但我现在从事研究工作，我可以用任何我用的语言写代码。我现在是 Python 的超级粉丝。我其实不怎么写 C++ 或 Rust 代码。我写 Python 代码来帮我写 C++ 和 Rust 代码，因为那样容易得多。我们将在以后的节目中讨论这一点，当我能谈论我正在做的主目时。但 Python 太棒了。在我们所谓的四个月假期期间，我们其实没有在度假，但我们录制了大量的节目。
I believe it was sometime in August I was listening to CppCast, the number one C++ podcast. We're number two. And I'm going to queue it up. Actually, I think I've got to share my screen. I'm going to go. We're number two. And I'm going to queue it up. Actually, I think I got to share my screen. I'm going to go with a distant number two. I don't actually know. I mean, based on number of subscribers, yes. But based on number of monthly views,
我相信大概是在 8 月份的某个时候，我在听 CppCast，排名第一的 C++ 播客。我们排名第二。我要把它放出来。事实上，我想我得共享我的屏幕。我要去。我们排名第二。我要把它放出来。事实上，我想我得共享我的屏幕。我要去一个远落后的第二名。我其实不知道。我的意思是，根据订阅者数量来看，是的。但根据每月观看次数来看，
we're actually pretty close to them. We're actually pretty close to them. All right. Episode 367 from CppCast, where they are interviewing Mark Gillard. I apologize about the pronunciation. And we're going to hear from Timur Dumler. We're just going to listen to a few seconds here. And this is on the status, because this episode is talking about a library that is, I think it talks about SOA versus AOS, which is structure of arrays versus array of structs, and a library that is called Soagen. And they're talking about reflection, and then at some
我们其实跟他们差得很近。我们其实跟他们差得很近。好的。来自 CppCast 的第 367 期节目，他们正在采访马克·吉拉德（Mark Gillard）。发音如有不当，敬请见谅。我们还将听到蒂穆尔·杜姆勒（Timur Dumler）的声音。我们在这里听几秒钟。这是关于现状的，因为这期节目讨论了一个库，我想它讨论的是 SOA 与 AOS，也就是结构体数组（structure of arrays）与数组结构体（array of structs），以及一个叫做 Soagen 的库。他们在谈论反射，然后在某一个
point, Timur opines or comments on the status of reflection. And actually, a few minutes earlier, Bryce, you get mentioned because of your ACCU talk, which I believe was the, you know, top three features that you're looking forward to in C++26 or C++ of the future. Anyways, Bryce, take a listen. And I will cut this in for the listener as well. Don't worry, I'm not going to leave you hanging. But yeah, I think there's not actually that much going on currently in the reflection study group.
时间点，蒂穆尔对反射的现状发表了看法或评论。事实上，就在几分钟前，布莱斯，你被提及了，因为你的 ACCU 演讲，我相信那是你在 C++26 或未来的 C++ 中最期待的前三大特性。不管怎样，布莱斯，听听看。我也会为听众把这段剪辑进去。别担心，我不会晾着你们不管的。不过，是的，我觉得反射研究组目前其实没有太多进展。
I think the work there has kind of stalled. I think they kind of ran out of funding for like to keep working on these papers and compiler forks or something. I don't know. I don't think there's much going on there at the moment. Unfortunate. All right. You heard that, Bryce? Yeah. I mean,
我觉得那里的工作有点停滞了。我觉得他们大概是资金用完了，比如无法继续开发这些论文和编译器分支什么的。我不知道。我觉得目前那里没发生什么事。真不幸。好的。你听到了吗，布莱斯？对。我的意思是，
I think that's not inaccurate. That's not inaccurate. So, you know, that's the first clip. And this is the first, this was the first little seed that got planted in my mind. And I thought, uh-oh. I mean, actually, that's not true. There's been a lot of seeds from before that. But the first time on a podcast.
我觉得这并非不准确。并非不准确。所以，你知道，这是第一段剪辑。这是在我脑海中种下的第一颗小种子，我想，糟了。我的意思是，其实这不对。之前已经有很多颗种子了。但这是第一次在播客上。
And then fast forward a couple weeks. I, of course, am doing the, you know, well, I wouldn't say it's the chore. I am enjoying a bunch of podcasts right now. Two of them, Software Unscripted and Oxide and Friends. I have been going back to episode zero and watching or watching, listening to the entire backlog as one does. And on episode 44, episode 44, entitled Books in the Box Redux, where they go through and they talk about all these books that are worth reading. What do you think the first book they talk about is, Bryce? ADSP.
然后快进几周。我当然正在做，呃，嗯，我不会说这是件苦差事。我现在很喜欢听一堆播客。其中两个是 Software Unscripted 和 Oxide and Friends。我一直在回看第零期，观看或者说聆听整个过往的节目归档，就像大家常做的那样。在第 44 期，第 44 期题为“重读箱中的书（Books in the Box Redux）”，他们在节目中盘点并讨论了所有值得一读的书籍。你觉得他们谈论的第一本书是什么，布莱斯？ADSP。
That's not a book. Yeah, Algorithms and Data Structures Post-Programs is a book, famously. That's why we hit the podcast. That's classic, yes. Elements of Programming. No, the book that they talk about is Beautiful C++. Oh. Which is a recent book by a couple of well-known people that are going to get mentioned in this.
那不是书。对，众所周知，《算法与数据结构后传》（Algorithms and Data Structures Post-Programs）是一本书。这就是我们做播客的原因。这很经典，是的。《编程元素》（Elements of Programming）。不，他们谈论的书是《美妙的 C++》（Beautiful C++）。哦。这是由几位将在节目中被提及的知名人士最近合著的一本书。
So we're going to listen to three minutes of this podcast. I think it's one of the rare C++ books that I have given my endorsement to, although I have not read it. All right, Bryce. Well, strap in, strap in, because this is good. We're going to listen to a minute and then we're going to skip ahead and we're going to listen to another couple minutes. So here we go. I mean, have you looked at modern C++? Yes. It's called a brush. I mean, it's like, why would you spend time on modern C++? No, no, no. I mean, that is the punchline,, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
所以我们要听这个播客的三分钟。我认为这是我给予背书的极少数 C++ 书籍之一，尽管我没有读过它。好的，布莱斯。好吧，系好安全带，系好安全带，因为这很精彩。我们要听一分钟，然后跳过前面，再听另外几分钟。所以我们开始吧。我的意思是，你看过现代 C++ 吗？是的。这简直像个刷子。我的意思是，为什么要把时间浪费在现代 C++ 上？不，不，不。我的意思是，那是笑点，
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no But seriously, every page of it strikes me not as beautiful, but as disgusting and as basically an advertisement for Rust. Like, yeah, C++ got all these things wrong.
不，不，不……但说真的，它的每一页给我的感觉都不是美妙，而是令人作呕，基本上就是 Rust 的广告。就像，是的，C++ 把所有这些事情都搞砸了。
All of the defaults made sense in the Jurassic era, but now here we are. And so the defaults don't need to all be wrong. The defaults can all be right. And it is called Rust. But it has definitely given me an appreciation for programming languages generally and for Rust specifically as a reaction to some of the shortcomings of Suplug. So look, look, okay.
所有的默认设置在侏罗纪时代可能是合理的，但现在我们身处这里。所以默认设置不一定全都是错的。默认设置全都可以是正确的。而它被称为 Rust。但这确实让我对编程语言本身以及特别是对 Rust 产生了一种欣赏，这是对 C++ 一些缺点的一种反应。所以看，看，好吧。
All right. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. No, no, no, no, no, no. We got two more minutes. We got two more minutes. I got some thoughts. Look, I like to shit on C++ as much as the next person. And I'm a member of the committee. Are you still a member of the committee?
好吧。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。不，不，不，不，不，不。我们还有两分钟。我们还有两分钟。我有一些想法。听着，我跟任何人一样喜欢吐槽 C++。而且我是委员会的成员。你现在还是委员会的成员吗？
Until my recent retirement, I was chair of the Library Evolution Group. And I feel like that gives me... But the thing is, if you're going to shit on C++, I feel like you need to have some credentials to do so. Like, I've been doing C++ for 10 years. If I want to talk shit about C++, I feel that I am qualified and have earned the right to do so. Some dude talking about modern C++
直到最近退休前，我一直担任库演进组（Library Evolution Group）的主席。我觉得这给了我……但问题是，如果你要吐槽 C++，我觉得你需要有一些资历才能这么做。比如，我写了 10 年 C++。如果我想吐槽 C++，我觉得我有资格并且配得上这样做。某个家伙在谈论现代 C++
and how dynamic cast, which is a thing, but not a thing that you really use that much in modern c++ and how dynamic cast which is a thing but not a thing that you've really used that much in modern c++ and unique cast which is not a thing you know maybe you're not maybe you're not qualified to be talking talking out your ass not not the reaction i expected and we will get to your resignation as chair of lube, but we're going to first, we're going to listen to another two minutes. Retirement, whatever. Same, same difference. We're going to skip ahead to the very, very different things. Resigning is something that you do when you're fed up with something. Retirement is something that you do when you're tired. All right. The next two minutes from Oxide and Friends episode 44,
以及 dynamic cast 是怎么回事，但这并不是你在现代 C++ 中经常使用的东西，以及 dynamic cast 是怎么回事，但这并不是你在现代 C++ 中经常使用的东西，还有 unique cast，这根本不是个东西，你知道，也许你没有，也许你没有资格在这里胡说八道。这不是我预料的反应，我们会谈到你辞去 Lube 主席职务的事，但我们首先要听另外两分钟。退休，随便啦。都一样。我们要直接跳到完全不同的事情上去。辞职是你对某事忍无可忍时做的事。退休则是当你累了时做的事。好的。来自 Oxide and Friends 第 44 期的接下来两分钟，
Books in the Box Redux. And also, folks, go listen to the whole thing. There's a whole like 10-minute section where they talk about this book. It's fantastic. I absolutely love it. Here we go.
《重读箱中的书》。还有，各位，去听完整期节目吧。里面大约有 10 分钟的板块专门讨论这本书。太棒了。我绝对喜欢。我们开始吧。
So Beautiful C++ to you is just like, this is why we should have Rust. This is not... I mean, it is a... I'd actually recommend it. I think it's an interesting book. Are they going to put that on the back jacket? I'd actually recommend it.
所以《美妙的 C++》在你看来就像是，这就是我们为什么应该拥有 Rust。这不……我的意思是，它是一个……我其实会推荐它。我认为这是一本有趣的图书。他们会把这个印在封底上吗？我其实会推荐它。
Raves to Adam Levithal. I do want to see if I can get... So the authors are Guy Davidson and Kate Gregory. And I would be very interested to see... And I've looked all over to see if they acknowledge Rust. And the closest I could find on Twitter was Guy Davidson saying, I don't really have time to try new languages, which is such a shame. Because these are folks who really have nuanced, deep thinking on this very important language. This is not the disparage C++, but one that they are themselves ready
向亚当·莱维瑟尔（Adam Leventhal）欢呼。我很想看看我能不能拿到……所以作者是盖伊·戴维森（Guy Davidson）和凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）。我很想看看——我到处找过，看他们是否承认 Rust。我在 Twitter 上能找到最接近的言论是盖伊·戴维森说：“我真的没有时间尝试新语言，”这太遗憾了。因为这些人对这门非常重要的语言有着真正细致、深刻的思考。这并不是要贬低 C++，而是他们自己已经准备好
to acknowledge the burrs and the mistakes of. And I'd love to see what they think of Rust just because I feel like, seriously, every page is just more and more of an advertisement for it. And when you get into concepts, concept is a concept in C++. Whoa! And yes, I had not heard of that.
承认其中的芒刺和错误。我很想看看他们对 Rust 的看法，因为我觉得，说真的，每一页都越来越像它的广告。当你接触到 concepts 时，concept 是 C++ 中的一个概念。哇！而且，是的，我没听说过那个。
There's a thing called concepts? There's a thing called concepts that is a bit like a trait. But people are gonna like, big pillory for making that kind of gross analogy there. But it's for describing the characteristics of a template. The type T needs to obey these parameters perfectly. Huh.
有个东西叫 concepts？有个东西叫 concepts，它有点像 trait（特征）。但人们会，因为作了这种粗糙的类比而遭到猛烈抨击。但它是用来描述模板的特征的。类型 T 需要完美地遵守这些参数。哈。
Okay. All right. I got to say, people like this are the reason that people dislike Rust. And not like on a technical level. What do you mean people dislike rust and not like on a technical level what do you mean people dislike rust it's the number one most loved language in the right but there's a reason that that that rust has a has a reputation for um over the top uh evangelism and it's i mean like i just they i think they have a very uneducated take. And honestly, I think somebody saying, I don't have time to learn new languages is a very legitimate and reasonable take. If you're, if you're, in this case, the person in question is, you know, a very senior programmer at a game studio. Like, his day job isn't to learn new programming languages. His day job isn't being a programming language person
好吧。好吧。我得说，像这样的人就是人们讨厌 Rust 的原因。而且不是在技术层面上。你这话什么意思，人们讨厌 Rust 且不是在技术层面上，你这话什么意思，人们讨厌 Rust，它是最受喜爱的语言第一名，在正确的但是，之所以 Rust 拥有……有一个名声，关于……过度宣传，我的意思是，就像我——我觉得他们的看法非常无知。老实说，我觉得有人说“我没有时间学习新语言”是一个非常合法和合理的观点。如果你，如果你——在这种情况下，当事人是一个游戏工作室的资深程序员。他的日常工作不是学习新的编程语言。他的日常工作不是成为一个编程语言专家
or a compiler person. His day job is, like, he has to make games, you know? Like, he's got shit to do. He doesn't necessarily have time to go and learn a new language, much less figure out how his organization's going go and learn a new language much less figure out how his organization's going to switch to a new language like that that's to to act like oh it's such a shame that that that these people won't open up their hearts and minds to new languages like come on no that that that is a bullshit um take and and that is like, it's making it sound like, oh, these people are, you know,
或编译器专家。他的日常工作是，他必须制作游戏，你知道吗？就像，他有一堆事情要做。他未必有时间去学习一门新语言，更不用说去弄清楚他的组织将如何去学习一门新语言，更不用说弄清楚他的组织将如何转而使用一门新语言了——那种行为，就好像“真遗憾，这些人不愿意向新语言敞开心扉和头脑”，拜访，得了吧，不，那是一种胡扯的看法，而且这听起来好像，哦，这些人是，你知道的，
living in medieval times and refuse to change. I think it is not at all unreasonable to recognize that there is an inherent and large cost to learning and adopting new languages. In fact, that's why the barrier to entry for new programming languages is so hard. I think we've talked about this in the podcast before that, you know, a programming language really needs to be 10x better than its competitors on some angle. That's a theory that comes to us from Andre Al-Zandriscu. Like, well, why do you need to be 10x better for a programming language to be able to have a chance at being successful at breaking in? It's because it's so freaking hard to adopt new programming languages. Like, let's not trivialize that. You know, I don't have time to go and learn a new language.
生活在中世纪，拒绝改变。我认为，认识到学习和采用新语言存在着固有且巨大的成本，一点也不不合理。事实上，这就是新编程语言的门槛如此之高的原因。我想我们以前在播客里讨论过这一点，你知道的，一编程语言真的需要在某些方面比它的竞争对手好上 10 倍才行。这个理论来自于安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库（Andrei Alexandrescu）。比如，为什么一门编程语言需要好上 10 倍才有机会在市场上成功突破？这是因为采用新的编程语言太难了。我们不要把这一点轻描淡写。你知道，“我没有时间去学习一门新语言。”
And I'm a co-host on a podcast where we spend a good chunk of time learning new programming languages. We're all very busy people and learning a new language is not like a trivial thing that everybody can do, especially when you're like in the trenches, like building production software. So I think that there's plenty of ways to criticize C++ and promote the positive aspects of Rust, but I think that that is absolutely the wrong way to go about doing it. Anyways, I'm sure you had a point between... I'm not really seeing the thread between these two clips, so I'm going to let you continue, because I'm sure you have a purpose here.
而我是个播客的联合主持人，我们在节目里花了相当多的时间学习新的编程语言。我们都是非常忙碌的人，学习一门新语言并不是每个人都能随随便便做到的事情，特别是当你身处一线，比如在构建生产级软件的时候。所以我认为有很多方法可以批评 C++ 并推广 Rust 的积极方面，但我认为绝对不应该用那种方式去进行。不管怎样，我确信你在……之间有一个观点。我真的看不出这两段剪辑之间有什么联系，所以我让你继续，因为我确信你在这里有你的目的。
Oh, no no this is fantastic I mean recall that at the end of episode 149 you said that you did think the answer to the question is c++ dying was yes but that is juxtaposed with your response to each of these well you said it's not true to say that reflection is stalled and the CPP. No, no, no. Sorry. I think I was pretty clear when I said that, no, yes, that's pretty accurate. Reflection is stalled. Yes.
哦，不，不，这太棒了。请记住，在第 149 期的结尾，你说过你确实认为关于“C++ 是否正在消亡”这个问题的答案是“是”，但那与你对其中每个观点的回应形成了对比——好吧，你说过“说反射停滞不前不是真的”以及 Cpp. 不，不，不。抱歉。我觉得我说得很清楚，不，是的，这相当准确。反射停滞了。是的。
And that is definitely a separate clip and really nothing to do – well, I'll say what they have to do with each other. But just to be very clear, yes, I think that Teamer's analysis was quite accurate. That's what I said. And by accurate, I mean that he said that it stalled and that the people who were working on it had kind of run out of funding and energy and time. And yeah, that's correct. That's what happened.
这绝对是一个独立的剪辑，跟——好吧，我会说说它们之间有什么关系。但为了非常明确起见，是的，我认为蒂穆尔的分析相当准确。这就是我所说的。所谓的准确，是指他说反射已经停滞，而且从事这项工作的人的资金、精力和时间都快耗尽了。是的，这是对的。这就是发生的事情。
So yeah, I don't, I mean, I'll have to re-listen to exactly, and I'm not even going to know the individual's names because there's so many people that talk on Oxide and Friends. I know Brian Cantrell was one of the voices and he actually was a C and C++ developer from years ago but has just not used the language. Yeah well he hasn't been a C++ developer since like the 90s I'm going to guess. Look if they want to have a real conversation about the merits of C++, they should invite me on their podcast. I mean, okay, fine. But my – so I don't actually think they were trying to be – like when the individual that was speaking said that he wanted to see if either of the authors had opinions, I don't think he said like, oh, it's terrible that they don't have opinions on Rust.
所以，是的，我没有——我的意思是，我得重新听一下具体内容，我甚至都记不住那些人的名字，因为在 Oxide and Friends 里说话的人太多了。我知道布莱恩·坎特雷尔（Brian Cantrell）是其中一个声音，他其实是多年前的 C 和 C++ 开发者，但只是不再使用这门语言了。是的，好吧，我猜他从 90 年代起就不是 C++ 开发者了。听着，如果他们想就 C++ 的优点进行一次真正的对话，他们应该邀请我去他们的播客。我的意思是，好吧，行。但我的——所以我其实不认为他们是在刻意——就像当那个说话的个体说他想看看两位作者是否有看法时，我不认为他是说，哦，他们对 Rust 没有看法太糟糕了。
They need to go learn Rust. I think he was just saying it's a shame that they don't have opinions because he was looking for them. And I... Yeah, I think there's a better way about expressing his message, a more nuanced way of doing that.
他们需要去学习 Rust。我想他只是说，真遗憾他们没有发表看法，因为他在寻找他们的看法。而我……是的，我觉得有更好的方式来表达他的信息，一种更细致的方式来做到这一点。
But I mean, I'm somebody who has a lot of hot takes too, so... Yeah, I was going to say, I mean... I just think my hot takes are better than, I mean, I was so thoroughly entertained, not just for the first 20 minutes of that podcast, but like for the full 90 because they end up talking about some other books that were fantastic at the end. It was just such an entertaining podcast. But I think in general, their point is that like Rust fixes a ton of the stuff
但我的意思是，我也是一个有很多尖锐观点的人，所以……是的，我正要说，我的意思是……我只是觉得我的尖锐观点比——我的意思是，我受到了极大的娱乐，不仅是那期播客的前 20 分钟，而是整整 90 分钟，因为他们最后讨论了一些在结尾处非常精彩的其他书籍。这真是一个极具娱乐性的播客。但我认为总的来说，他们的观点是 Rust 修正了大量
that C++ got wrong and looking at a quote-unquote... Yeah, but Rust also has problems as well. Yes, yes. Every language has problems. Let me finish my point. My point though is that reading or skimming through, I'm not sure actually to what extent, you know, he read the book, but reading like a modern C++ book, which is effectively like they took a subset of the modern guidelines and then bookified it with examples it's like coming from a language like rust is kind of painful to see like our workarounds and our guidelines for dealing with you know lots of corners of c++ that are basically like like, no longer a problem in Rust.
C++ 搞砸的东西，而且看一个所谓的……是的，但 Rust 也有问题。是的，是的，每门语言都有问题。让我把话说完。不过我的观点是，阅读或浏览——我其实不确定他阅读的程度如何，你知道，他读了多少——但阅读一本现代 C++ 书籍，这实际上就像他们提取了现代准则的一个子集，然后把带例子的东西做成了书，从像 Rust 这样的语言转过来，看我们的变通方案和处理 C++ 中许多角落的准则，会觉得有点痛苦，那些角落基本上……在 Rust 中已经不再是问题了。
Like, I think their observation there is accurate, if not, you know, in your opinion, delivered in the best way. I thought it was delivered fantastically because I just want to be – like, when I was listening to that podcast, that's what I – I can't remember which – oh, when we were interviewing Rob while walking in Venice. And he was trying to be politically, you know, sensitive about what he said about Q and KDB+, and I was like, feel free to give hot takes, man. It's what drives ratings. And my point that is connected between the two is that I listened to that first one about how reflection has stalled, and keep in mind that that is one of the top three things that you were looking forward to. And when you add the two others on that list, one of the other ones is pattern matching with, from what I can tell, if you pay attention to the mailing, like, I would be very surprised if either reflection or pattern matching made it into C++26. I will make a bolder statement.
我觉得他们在那里的观察是准确的，即使（在你看来的话）并不是以最好的方式表达出来的。我觉得它表达得妙极了，因为我只想——就像我在听那个播客时，那就是我——我不记得是哪个——哦，我们在威尼斯散步时采访罗布（Rob）的时候。他在试图对关于 Q 和 KDB+ 的言论保持政治敏感性，而我就像，放心地说出尖锐的观点吧，老兄。这才是驱动收视率的东西。我联系这两者的观点是，我听了第一关于反射如何停滞的第一段音频，请记住，那是你最期待的前三件事之一。而当你把另外两件事加到那个列表上时，其中另一件就是模式匹配（pattern matching）。据我所能判断的，如果你关注邮件列表的话，如果有反射或模式匹配进入 C++26，我会非常惊讶。我要说得更大胆一点。
I will be very surprised if any major language feature ships in C++ 26. There you go. And I'll make a bolder statement. I'll be very surprised if any major language feature ships in C++ period. Like ever? 29? 32? Yeah. Alright. I can
如果有任何重大的语言特性在 C++26 中发布，我会非常惊讶。给你。而且我要说得更大胆一点。如果有任何重大的语言特性在 C++ 中发布，不管是哪一年，我都会非常惊讶。就像永远不会？29年？32年？对。好吧。我能
see, I think there's more behind, or actually, instead of me, you know, opining on why I think you're making that, would you like to explain why you think that is the case? Yeah, I think that the committee has grown so slow, the committee process has become so slow and antiquated that it is, the cycles upon which we develop these major features, it's just so long now, and especially relative to a language like Rust. And the pandemic was very disruptive
看出，我觉得这背后有更多原因，或者实际上，与其由我来发表高见，解释为什么我认为你会有这种看法，你愿意解释一下为什么你认为会是这样吗？是的，我认为委员会已经变得太慢了，委员会的流程已经变得如此缓慢和陈旧，以至于我们开发这些重大特性的周期现在变得太长了，尤其是相对于 Rust 这样的语言而言。大流行对
to the language evolution part of C++ because essentially it was put more or less fully on hold for two to three years. And after you take a break for something for two to three years, it can be really hard to get it started again. On the library side of things, we didn't take a two to three year break. We forged ahead. We found new ways of working. We modernized our process. That happened to some degree on the language side of things, but essentially the policy was, well, we'll modernize our process. We'll work on things during the pandemic, but really we'll just work on the small things. And I think a lot of the major contributors and collaborators in C++ on the language side did not, have not accepted into their hearts and souls the fundamental tenets
C++ 的语言演进部分造成了极大的破坏，因为它基本上被搁置了整整两到三年。在你因为某事休息两到三年之后，想要重新开始会非常困难。在库这一边，我们并没有休息两到三年。我们勇往直前。我们找到了新的工作方式。我们现代化了我们的流程。这在语言这一边也在某种程度上发生过，但基本上政策是，“好吧，我们会现代化我们的流程。我们会在大流行期间做一些事情，但实际上我们只会做一些小事情。”而且我认为 C++ 中语言方面的许多主要贡献者和合作者并没有、也没有将远程工作和异步工作的基本原则、理念和哲学
and ideas and philosophy of remote work and asynchronous work. And that has made it very hard for us to really truly modernize how we operate. And a lot of people have disengaged. You know, they stopped participating during the pandemic and they haven't come back. And I mean, you know, if you're somebody who believes that, oh, the only way that we can work on the C++ is the special and unique language, that even though C and Fortran and COBOL and Pascal
铭记在心并融入灵魂。这使得我们很难真正地现代化我们的运作方式。许多人退出了。你知道，他们在疫情期间停止了参与，而且再也没有回来。我的意思是，你知道，如果你是一个认为“哦，我们唯一能研究 C++ 这种特殊且独特的语言的方式……”的人，尽管 C、Fortran、COBOL、Pascal、
and Rust and Swift and Python, even though all the other languages on the face of the earth have been able to figure out a way to evolve that's not required meeting in person three times a year. And that's the only time when we can do work. If you believe that C++ is special and the things that apply to other languages don't apply to C++, well, we're in an environment now where not everybody can go and fly three times a year to some remote destination to go work on this language. We've not really made it easy or possible or been mindful of remote participants in the committee process. And so we've created this environment where we've made it very, very difficult, especially in the current environment, to be involved in C++ language evolution. And this has greatly decreased, I think, the number of people that are involved. And also at the same time, we've lost a lot of contributors after the pandemic, people who have just chosen not to come back, and also people who have chosen to invest in other languages because they see the writing on the wall. So yeah, I think it's going to be a while before we ship major language features in C++.
还有 Rust、Swift 和 Python，尽管地球上所有其他的语言都已经能够找到一种不需要每年面对面开会三次的演进方式。而那才是我们能工作的唯一时间。如果你认为 C++ 是特殊的，适用于其他语言的东西不适用于 C++，好吧，我们现在身处的环境是，并不是每个人都能每年飞三次去某个偏远目的地来研究这门语言。我们在委员会流程中并没有真正让远程参与者感到轻松、可能或予以关注。因此，我们创造了这样一个环境，使得参与 C++ 语言演进变得非常非常困难，特别是在当前的环境下。这大大减少了参与的人数，我认为。而且与此同时，在大流行之后我们失去了许多贡献者，有些人选择不再回来，还有些人因为看到了大势所趋而选择投资其他语言。所以，是的，我认为在 C++ 中发布重大语言特性还需要一段时间。
And I don't know that the current process is going to work for us. And I think unless we come up with a new process, we may not ship major language features again. And I want to be clear about something here, too, that why do I think C++ is dying? I don't think it has anything to do with the particular technical merits of the C++ language. I think the number one thing that's going to kill C++ is the C++ evolution process.
而且我不知道当前的流程是否对我们行之有效。我认为，除非我们想出一个新的流程，否则我们可能再也不会发布重大的语言特性了。在这里我也想澄清一件事，为什么我认为 C++ 正在消亡？我认为这与 C++ 语言的具体技术优点没有任何关系。我认为将杀死 C++ 的头号杀手是 C++ 的演进流程。
Because at the end of the day, it doesn't matter where C++ is relative to Rust. Like, if you think about where the languages are, how good the languages are today, think about that as your velocity. That's not relevant. The relevant thing is the acceleration. And by acceleration, I mean the pace and the quality of the language's evolution process. Now, admittedly,
因为归根结底，C++ 相对于 Rust 处于什么位置并不重要。如果你考虑这些语言所处的位置、这些语言今天有多好，把这当作你的速度（velocity）。这并不相关。相关的是加速度（acceleration）。我所说的加速度，是指语言演进流程的步伐和质量。现在，必须承认，
the Rust evolution process, it's got some problems. Rust has had a good bit of drama in recent years. But those have been problems that I would characterize as primarily political problems in the evolution process of Rust. And there are many languages that have political problems. However, the procedural and logistical aspects of the Rust evolution model are drastically better than C++. And so while yes, Rust and C++ both share some of the same types of political problems in evolution, which honestly any project is going to have political problems. And if you don't accept that as reality, you're not going to go far. But that's really the thing that's going to kill C++.
Rust 的演进流程也有一些问题。Rust 近年来经历了不少戏剧性事件。但这些问题我可以将其定性为 Rust 演进流程中主要是政治性的问题。有许多语言都存在政治问题。然而，Rust 演进模型的程序和后勤方面比 C++ 好得多。因此，尽管 Rust 和 C++ 在演进中确实分享了某些相同类型的政治问题，老实说，任何项目都会有政治问题，如果你不接受这个现实，你就走不远。但真正会杀死 C++ 的，确实是这个。
It's not that C++ is a worse language compared to Rust today, although I think there's certainly ways in which it is. The problem is, where is C++ going to be in 10 years from now? The problem is that you and I, two people who have prominent careers in C++, we both aren't confident that C++ is going to be able to ship any major language features in the next three-year cycle. And even if we did ship a major language feature in C++ 26, which is, again, three years from now, let's say that we shipped pattern matching and reflection in C++ 26, How long would it take before those features are deployed in compilers and people can actually use them?
并不是因为今天的 C++ 与 Rust 相比是一门更差的语言，尽管我认为它在某些方面确实如此。问题在于，从现在起 10 年后 C++ 将会在哪里？问题在于你和我，两个在 C++ 领域拥有显赫职业生涯的人，我们都不确定 C++ 是否能够在下一个三年周期内发布任何重大的语言特性。即使我们在 C++26 中发布了一个重大的语言特性——这再次强调是三年后，假设我们在 C++26 中发布了模式匹配和反射——从这些特性被部署到编译器中并真正供人们使用，需要多长时间？
It probably wouldn't be until 27, 28. That's like five years from now. If I go to my management... That's generous. I know modules was a different kind of feature, but it is 2023, and we still don't have like in a single compiler i know that there are varying levels and there's starting to be articles you know tristan had one on implement using modules but like it is not like a baked feature that people can just go use
可能要到 27 年、28 年。那已经是大约五年后的事了。如果我去找我的管理层……这已经很慷慨了。我知道模块（modules）是一种不同类型的特性，但现在已经是 2023 年了，我们仍然没有——比如在单个编译器中——我知道存在不同的成熟度级别，并且开始出现一些文章，你知道，特里斯坦（Tristan）有一篇关于使用模块进行实现的，但这并不是一个烘焙完成、人们可以随时去使用的特性，
regardless of compiler that they're using and so to say that we're going to be able to use a language feature in 27 after it ships in 26, I think is generous. And so the language features that ship in 26, we're not going to be using them until C++ 29 or 30. And if they don't make 26, which I think is pretty likely, I think they would make 29 at earliest,
无论他们使用的是哪个编译器，所以说什么我们能够在 27 年使用一个在 26 年发布的语言特性，我认为这已经很慷慨了。因此，26 年发布的语言特性，我们要到 C++29 或 30 年才能使用它们。如果它们没赶上 26 年，而我认为这相当有可能，我觉得它们最早也要到 29 年才能赶上，
we'd be talking like 30, 31, 32, 33. That's 10 years from now. Can you imagine all of the things that are going to happen in the next 10 years? Can you imagine all of the work that Rust is going to get done in the next five years, in the next 10 years? Can you imagine all the work that all these other languages, you know, I'm skeptical about the prospects of some of the various C++ successor languages, but certainly I'm not skeptical that none of them will succeed. I think probably something will come out of some of them. You know, can you imagine in five years where a language like VAL would be, where something like Carbon would be, where something like Circle would be. Think about all the stuff that could get done in five years. Think about
我们谈论的将是 30、31、32、33 年。那是从现在起 10 年后。你能想象在未来 10 年里将要发生的所有事情吗？你能想象 Rust 在未来五年、未来 10 年里将完成的所有工作吗？你能想象所有这些其他语言将完成的所有工作吗——我对某些 C++ 继承者语言的前景持怀疑态度，但我当然不怀疑它们之中没有任何一个会成功。我想其中某些语言大概会孕育出一些成果。你知道，你能想象在五年后，像 VAL 这样的语言会怎样，像 Carbon 这样的语言会怎样，像 Circle 这样的语言会怎样。想想在五年内可以完成的所有事情。想想
all the work that just Sean Baxter, one person, one guy, could get done in the next five years. And think in parent to the work that we're likely to get out of the C++ committee and C++ implementations. And that is the thing that's going to kill C++, is that the process has become so archaic and so gridlocked and so risk adverse that we've lost all agility and eventually everybody else is going to pass us. We haven't reached that point yet, but eventually we will. And like when I say we haven't reached that point yet, like, yeah, we do have a lot of glaring deficiencies. But those deficiencies aren't currently like 10x deficiencies. But we will reach a point where they really will be. And how do we solve the problem? Well, I think the solution is that we have to radically change
仅仅肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）一个人、一个人在未来五年里就能完成的所有工作。再想想相比之下我们可能从 C++ 委员会和 C++ 实现中获得的工作。正是这一点将杀死 C++，因为这个流程已经变得如此陈旧、陷入如此严重的僵局并且如此规避风险，以至于我们失去了所有的灵活性，最终其他人都会超越我们。我们还没有到达那个点，但最终我们会到达的。就像我说我们还没到达那个点一样，是的，我们确实有很多明显的缺陷。但这些缺陷目前还不是那种 10 倍的缺陷。但我们会到达那个真正成为 10 倍缺陷的点。我们如何解决这个问题？好吧，我认为解决办法是，我们必须从根本上改变
how we evolve the C++ language. Yeah, this is fantastic. So I had in a Google Docs a title, is C++ dying? And then eight bullet points. You basically filled in, I think, three of them. The first one was CppCast, where the quote about, you know, there's no progress being made on reflection, which obviously isn't great if you want to see reflection in the language, which I think is more emblematic of the fact of what you're talking
我们演进 C++ 语言的方式。是的，这太棒了。所以我在谷歌文档里有一个标题，叫“C++ 正在消亡吗？”，然后有八个要点。你基本上填补了其中的三个，我想。第一个是 CppCast，里面提到了关于“反射没有取得进展”的言论，如果你的愿景是希望在语言中看到反射，这显然不是什么好事，我认为这更象征着你正在谈论的事实，
about is how the committee is not making progress on a lot of things that have been being worked, like pattern matching first showed up before C++17 as a proposal. It was baked alongside with variant. It's like variant and pattern matching initially showed up at the committee as one proposal. So now we are, you know, coming in on close to a decade if they come, if they show up in C++26, which we both don't think is going to happen. You know, fingers crossed, would love to see it, but don't think it's going to happen. So anyways, the point is, is that committee issues. Number five on the list was the Oxide and Friends clip, which is just highlighting that there are alternatives that for a lot of folks is just way more attractive than C++. You basically touched on number two and number six, where I
也就是委员会如何在许多一直在进行的工作上无法取得进展，比如模式匹配在 C++17 之前作为提案首次出现。它与 variant 一起被孕育。就像 variant 和 pattern matching 最初作为同一个提案出现在委员会中一样。所以现在，如果它们出现在 C++26 中——我们俩都认为这不会发生——我们已经接近走过十年了。你知道，祈祷好运，很乐意看到它发生，但并不认为它会发生。所以无论如何，重点是，委员会存在问题。清单上的第五项是 Oxide and Friends 的剪辑，它只是强调了存在一些替代方案，对许多人来说，这些方案比 C++ 具有更大的吸引力。你基本上触及了第二项和第六项，其中我
have written that, like, I know multiple people that basically don't attend committee meetings anymore, whether that's because of the pandemic, or it's because of other reasons. But I definitely know of folks that I've spoken to that are no longer engaged in the ISO committee C++ process for one reason or another. And I think that is showing in the lack of progress on certain features, whether that's in the language side or library side. On top of this, number six, which I think you kind of mentioned, you know, referenced, is the fact that I'm not even sure. I don't think Google would agree with this statement, but I'm interested to hear your take. My point is that Google is largely moving away from C++, or at least they're making a bet on Carbon to have this happen. And I think that is
写下了，比如，我认识好几个人基本上不再参加委员会会议了，无论是由于疫情原因，还是由于其他原因。但我确实知道一些我交谈过的人，因为这样或那样的原因不再参与 ISO C++ 委员会的流程了。我认为这在某些特性缺乏进展上表现得很明显，无论是在语言方面还是在库方面。除此之外，第六项——我想你有点提到了，引用了——那就是我甚至不确定。我不认为谷歌会同意这种说法，但我很有兴趣听听你的看法。我的观点是，谷歌在很大程度上正在远离 C++，或者至少他们正在押注 Carbon 来实现这一点。我认为这
not only, you know, impactful in terms of that they're trying to make a successor language, but also the people that stepped back from the committee was like a huge loss. Oh, yeah. We don't need to list off their names, but there are a ton of very, very bright folks that are working on Carbon that previously used to spend a lot of time at committee meetings running different groups. And those folks, they have been replaced by other Google employees. But, you know, I think it is... Have they? There are a lot less people
不仅在他们试图创造一门继承者语言方面具有影响力，而且那些退出委员会的人也是一个巨大的损失。哦，是的。我们不需要一一列举他们的名字，但在 Carbon 上工作着大量非常非常优秀的人，他们以前常常花大量时间在委员会会议上运营不同的组。而那些人，他们已经被其他谷歌员工取代了。但是，你知道，我认为这是……真的被取代了吗？今天谷歌在 C++ 委员会上的
from Google on the C++ committee today. Yeah, I do know that there are people that still from Google that go to committee meetings. But yeah, I think the numbers that they used to send and also to like the people with the depth of expertise, and that's not to say that the new people that are going, because actually I'm not even super familiar with them. But just like, you know, for instance, like one name, Richard Smith. I think it was a huge loss to C++ when Richard Smith stepped back and started working on Carbon. Anyways, and there's a couple others. But just in general, I have started to see this like picture form over the last year or so. And I think we've even, you know, we at the beginning of the year, we had that fantastic recording where you made the Star Wars analogy of, you know, a new hope.
人数要少得多。是的，我确实知道谷歌仍然有人去参加委员会会议。但是，是的，我认为他们过去派遣的人数，以及那些具备深厚专业知识的人（这并不是说去的新人不好，因为实际上我甚至对他们不是很熟悉）——但就像，你知道，举个例子，理查德·史密斯（Richard Smith）。我认为当理查德·史密斯退居幕后并开始参与 Carbon 时，对 C++ 来说是一个巨大的损失。不管怎样，还有其他几个人。但总的来说，在过去的一年左右里，我开始看到这幅画面逐渐成型。而且我想我们甚至，你知道，我们在年初时有过那次精彩的录制，你打了一个《星球大战》的比方，关于“一个新的希望”，
And and, you know, we were kind of joking about, you know, we're in different phases if we equate this to Star Wars and, you know, what's going to happen to C++. It's going to be interesting to see. And the point being is that, like, having these two different podcasts that I listen to, one which is, like, the premier C++ podcast where they're talking about reflection and how progress has stalled, and then they're just like, yeah, that's unfortunate. I think that really we're starting to see, severe cracks in, in the C plus plus, you know, what do you want to call it? Language or evolution process is going to lead to quote unquote C plus plus
而且，你知道，我们当时还在开玩笑，如果我们把它比作《星球大战》，我们正处于不同的阶段，以及“C++ 会发生什么”。这将拭目以待。重点是，我有这两个不同的播客可以听，一个是顶级 C++ 播客，他们在节目中谈论反射以及进展如何停滞，然后他们就像，“是的，这真不幸。”我觉得我们真的开始看到，在 C++ 的……你愿意叫它什么？语言或演进流程中出现了严重的裂痕，这将导致所谓的 C++
dying. And I think that death has already started. And also too, I know that there are going to be, I don't think that these are new problems. It's, it's simply that we've, we're talking about the problems now it's it's it's been this
“消亡”。而且我认为这种死亡已经开始了。还有，我也知道肯定会有——我不认为这些是新问题。这只是……我们现在正在讨论这些问题，过去二十年来一直
way for the past two decades yeah but but i i know that there's going to be listeners too that are thinking c++ is doing just fine i think that was number seven on my list was it is it is it is doing just fine like right now like yeah so team or doomler he gave a a keynote at c++ on c where he said that basically we don't need to be worried about safety. It's being overblown. Go watch the talk if I'm misparaphrasing. But and then one of his points is that like C++ is going to be just fine.
都是这样的。是的，但我——我知道肯定也会有听众认为 C++ 现在过得挺好的。我想这大概是我清单上的第七项，就是它——它现在确实过得挺好的，就像现在这样——是的，所以蒂穆尔·杜姆勒（Timur Dumler）在 C++ on Sea 上发表了一次主旨演讲，他在演讲中基本上说我们不需要担心安全性。这被夸大了。如果我断章取义了，大家可以去看那次演讲。但他的观点之一是，C++ 会过得挺好的。
And I think that like if you don't like the word dying, replace the word dying with sun setting and be okay with the fact that basically the direction that C++ is headed is that direction of COBOL. If you are, you know, a C++ expert and you want to do C++ work for the rest of your career, even if you're, you know, just out of university, you can definitely do that. There is going to be C++ repositories that are, you know, big companies are working on, you 50 years from now there's no way that that but the thing is like like this this is not an inevitable future and that's one of the reasons why i made that star wars analogy is that like c++ is not doomed i do think it may be dying
而且我认为，如果你不喜欢“消亡”这个词，可以把它换成“日落”，并接受这样一个事实：基本上C++前进的方向就是COBOL的方向。如果你是一个C++专家，并且想在职业生涯的余下时间里从事C++工作，即使你刚大学毕业，你也完全可以做到这一点。会有一些C++代码库是大公司在维护的，从现在起50年后，这是肯定的。但问题是，这并不是一个不可避免的未来，这也是我打星球大战比喻的原因之一：C++并没有完蛋，但我确实认为它可能正在消亡。
but it's not doomed like we we could we could solve our problems if if if we had the will to do so. We could modernize our process. We could change the level of risk that we concern ourselves with. We could improve our stakeholder structure. We could find ways to move faster. So here's my question. Look, simple solution.
但它并没有完蛋，如果我们有愿望去解决问题，我们就能解决问题。我们可以使流程现代化。我们可以改变我们所关注的风险水平。我们可以改善利益相关者结构。我们可以找到更快前进的方法。所以我的问题是。看，有个简单的解决方案。
Deprecate all existing C++ implementations. Circle is now the reference implementation for C++ and appoint Sean Baxter the dictator for life. That's not going to happen though.
废弃所有现有的C++实现。Circle现在成为C++的参考实现，并任命肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）为终身独裁者。不过这不会发生。
That is not a realistic... But I'll tell you what, it would solve a lot of our problems. So here's the thing. You're saying technically as a former statistician actuary, that is a possible future.
那不是现实的……但我告诉你，这会解决我们的很多问题。所以情况是这样的。作为前精算师，你从技术上讲，那是一个可能的未来。
Not a probable future, but it is a possible future. That is not out of but it is a possible future that is not out of the realm of possibilities. That being said, it's not realistic, and that's why I think C++ is doomed. No, but that's the extreme version. I think that there's non-extreme versions.
不是一个大概率的未来，但它是一个可能的未来。那并非不可能，但它确实是一个可能的未来。话虽如此，它并不现实，这就是为什么我认为C++完蛋了。不，那是极端版本。我认为还有非极端版本。
I don't even think the non-extreme versions are going to happen, though. And here's the thing. Here's my question. I'll tell you what the problem is. Let me ask my question. If one of these non-extreme versions or the extreme versions happened, do you think that the people that have been turned away from the evolution process that are not involved would actually come back to the language? We don't need them.
不过，我甚至认为非极端版本也不会发生。情况是这样的。我的问题是。我来告诉你问题所在。让我问我的问题。如果这些非极端版本或极端版本之一发生了，你认为那些被演进过程拒之门外、没有参与的人真的会回到这个语言中吗？我们不需要他们。
You don't need them. The problem that C++ has, and Bjorn actually wrote this in his Vasa paper. He wrote about how C++ is 300 individual authors, each with their own goals and objectives, that we're not a team. We don't have a shared vision. Everybody comes to the committee with their own objectives and that's why something like reflection is failing. Why is reflection failing? Reflection is failing because there were three people working on it and two of those people are now working on something else and the other person doesn't really have the bandwidth to be able to fully commit to it. And that's because it was all their project
你不需要他们。C++遇到的问题，比雅尼（Bjarne）实际上在他的Vasa论文中写过。他写道，C++有300位独立的作者，每个人都有自己的目标和目的，我们不是一个团队。我们没有共同的愿景。每个人带着自己的目标来到委员会，这就是为什么像反射这样的东西会失败。为什么反射会失败？反射失败是因为有三个人在做这件事，其中两个人现在在做别的事情，而另一个人其实没有精力和带宽来全身心投入。这是因为这完全是他们自己的项目。
because on the C++ committee, everything is driven by individual authors. It's for many of the same reasons that I think that the Boost libraries have had trouble evolving and modernizing over time because the Boost libraries was a collection of 150 different libraries, each with an individual author.
因为在C++委员会上，一切都是由个人作者驱动的。这也是为什么我认为Boost库在随着时间推移演进和现代化时遇到困难的许多相同原因，因为Boost库是由150个不同的库组成的集合，每个库都有一个独立的作者。
And with the exception of Dave Abraham's, there was never really somebody in the Boost world who could make unilateral decisions, unilateral global decisions, like for example, to move Boost to a new build system, or to do any of the other things that might have helped Boost to be more successful than it currently is in the modern era.
除了戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）之外，在Boost世界里从来没有真正出现过能够做出单方面决定、单方面全局决定的人，比如将Boost迁移到新的构建系统，或者做任何其他可能帮助Boost在现代时代比目前更成功的事情。
And C++ has that same problem where it's a collection of 300 individual authors and champions. You know what? We don't need a committee of 300 people. The fact that we have 300 people on the committee is a problem. I don't need people to come back to the committee. Did we lose some really good people? Yeah. But we also have some good people. The problem is we have too many damn people. If you want C++ to be more successful, the real reason why it's going to be so hard to improve the C++ process is that to improve the C++ process,
C++也有同样的问题，它是一个由300位独立作者和倡导者组成的集合。你知道吗？我们不需要一个300人的委员会。委员会里有300人本身就是一个问题。我不需要人们回到委员会。我们是否失去了一些非常优秀的人？是的。但我们也有一些优秀的人。问题是我们有太多该死的人了。如果你希望C++取得更大的成功，那么要改善C++流程之所以如此困难，真正的原是因为要改善C++流程，
you need to get the 300 people who are currently on the committee, you need to get some large percentage of them to agree to disenfranchise themselves. You have to get a large chunk of those people to give up their power and their veto or their voice on the committee in favor of a lighter weight process to get some of the chefs out of the kitchen so that we can have a nimbler process. And like, that's really, I think the only way that we can realistically save C++ is that we need a different stakeholder model. We need a different evolution model
你需要让目前在委员会中的300人中的很大一部分人同意剥夺他们自己的权力。你必须让这群人中的很大一部分人放弃他们的权力和否决权，或者放弃他们在委员会中的发言权，转而采用一个更轻量级的流程，把一些厨子赶出厨房，这样我们就能拥有一个更敏捷的流程。所以，这真的是我们能够切实拯救C++的唯一途径，我们需要一个不同的利益相关者模型。我们需要一个不同的演进模型，
where we can make decisions in smaller rooms and where we can make decisions that are more implementation focused. And also where we can make greater investment in implementations, because one of the big problems that we have today is that implementations are just drastically understaffed. And you see this, like this is one of the reasons why it takes so long after we standardize a feature for it to get adopted. Like, you know, we talked about this earlier with modules. Like, why isn't, why don't we have modules everywhere? Well, it's because we don't have enough people contributing to all the compilers. And like I said, that is somebody who works at a company who is, who, or I have spent a
在那里我们可以在更小的房间里做出决策，做出更多以实现为重点的决策。而且在那里我们还可以对实现进行更多的投资，因为我们今天面临的巨大问题之一就是实现的人手严重不足。你可以看到这一点，这也是为什么我们在标准化一个特性后，需要这么长时间才能被采用的原因之一。就像我们之前谈到模块时所说的那样。为什么我们没有到处使用模块？嗯，那是因为我们没有足够的人为所有编译器做贡献。就像我说的，作为一个在公司工作的人，或者我在NVIDIA度过了很大一部分时间，倡导并让我们增加致力于语言前端的团队规模的人。你知道，为编译器、编程语言和核心库团队争取投资总是很难的，因为这通常具有难以直接与收入挂钩的无形效益。所以是的，我们不需要人们回来。我们需要一些参与C++演进的现有人员将权力移交给一个更小的机构，以便以更敏捷的方式做出决策。好了。那么让我们为ADSP播客第150期收尾，总结一下并提出以下问题。
good chunk of my time at NVIDIA advocating for and us to increase the size of the team that we have working on our language front-ends. You know, it's always hard to get investments for things like compilers and programming languages and for core library teams, because it often has non-tangible benefits that are hard to directly associate to revenue. So yeah, we don't need people to come back. We need some of the existing people who are involved in the evolution of C++ to give up power to a smaller body that can make decisions in a more nimble way. All right. So let's wind down, wrap up episode 150 of ADSP the podcast with the following summary slash question.
我们两个都已经回答过了。C++在消亡吗？布莱斯（Bryce）回答是，我也回答是。C++完蛋了吗？布莱斯的回答是不是，我的回答是是，这意味着我对最后一个问题的回答是：C++要改变方向，从消亡走向繁荣，所需要发生的变革是否存在现实的可能性？是的，我认为这是可能的。我甚至可以说，我认为这是很有可能的。但我认为事情在变好之前可能会变得更糟。
We already both answered. Is C++ dying? That's a yes from Bryce, a yes from me. Is C++ doomed? That's a no from Bryce and a yes for me, which means my answer to the final question, is there a realistic chance that the change that needs to occur for C++ to shift direction from dying to thriving? Yes, I think it's possible. I would even go so far as to say that I think it is likely. But I think that things will probably get worse before they get better.
但我认为，你知道的，会有下一代人。在某个时刻，领导层的权杖将从当前一代领导层传递给新一代领导层。我认为这代表了改革和变革的巨大机遇与潜力。我的意思是，我认为要让所有人都加入进来是很困难的。我很高兴这不是我的工作，而是别人的工作。我没有时间应对那种压力，但我认为还有其他人像我一样坚信，大势已去，如果我们不改变，如果我们不改进我们的流程，这门语言最终会消亡。我认为这是一个巨大的动力。
But I think that there is, you know, a next generation. At some point, there will be a passing of a torch from the current generation of leadership to a new generation of leadership. And I think that represents great opportunity and potential for reform and in change. I mean, I think it's going to be hard to get everybody on board. I'm glad that that is not my job, it's somebody else's job. I don't have the time for that sort of stress, but I think that there are others who believe as I do that the writing is on the wall and that if we don't change things, if we don't improve our process that the language will eventually die. And I think that is a great motivator.
而且我不认为把事情做好、进行改革和现代化会像人们想象的那么难。另外，我不认为C++是什么特殊的语言，以至于我们因为自己是C++就必须以某种特殊的方式做事。我们在如何合作和开发C++编程语言方面，落后了20到30年。还有其他和我们一样大甚至比我们更大的语言，它们已经找到了现代化的方法，我们也可以做到。所以最后的评论。我知道你，我想我认识那个你认为有生存危机且需要做出改变的人。但我只能想到一个。
And I don't think it's as hard as people make it out to be to make things better, to reform, to modernize. And also, I don't think that C++ is some special language where we have to do things a certain special way because we're C++. We are 20 to 30 years behind the curve in how we collaborate and work on the C++ programming language. And there are other languages that are as big or bigger than us that have found ways to modernize, we can do it too. So final comment. I know the person that you, I think I know the person or one of the people that you are saying believes that there is a existential threat and change needs to be made. But I can only think of one.
我不确定是不是有多个人。如果你知道他是谁，我会感到惊讶，因为他不是你最喜欢的人。哦，所以我们要消音，但它是……对吧？对，对。是的。你应该把它消音，但保留在录音里。
I'm not sure if there's multiple people. I would be surprised if you know who it is because it's not your favorite person. Oh, so we're going to bleep, but it's... Correct? Yeah, yeah. Yeah. And you should bleep it and leave that in there.
但是等等，等等，等等。我要给你一个更好的线索。我认为他是最适合拯救C++的人。是的，所以我确实猜对了这个人，我也同意他们是。哇，听到你这么说我很震惊。嘿，我有我个人的感受。而且我认为它不一定非得是
But wait, wait, wait. I'm going to give you a better clue. I think they are the person best equipped to save C++. Yes, so I did correctly guess this person, and I agree that they are. Wow, I'm shocked to hear you say that. Hey, I have my personal feelings. And I don't think that it needs to necessarily
那某一个特定的人。我只是觉得……好吧，这就是我的问题。有没有……因为我没有信心，那是唯一一个让我觉得还有希望的人，而且我不认为那个人会掌权。所以——你知道，我不知道。
be that one particular person. I just, I think that... Well, so that was my question. Are there, because I am not confident, like that's the only person I can think that there would be hope, and I don't think that person is going to get the reins. So – You know, I don't know.
他们可能会。他们可能会掌权。他们可能会。但如果整个C++的命运都悬于这一个人的晋升之上呢？我认为谁来领导委员会其实并没有那么重要。这更多是关于代际变革，即权力的交接正在发生。我认为在更多权力的交接发生之后，这将会迎来下一代领导层。即使某个人掌权，或者只是在其他角色中，我认为我们不可避免地会走向改革。
They might. They might get the reins. They might. But if all of C++ hinges on this one individual getting promoted? I think that it's far less important which particular person is running the committee. I think it's more about the generational change, that there is a passing of the torch that is undergoing. And I think after more of the passing of the torch has happened, this will sort of have the next generation of leadership. And even if a particular person is in charge versus is just is in some other role, I think that inevitably we will move towards reform.
我认为这里存在一个问题：改革的速度有多快？它来得足够快，真的能拯救这门语言吗？当我们做出所需的改进时，大势是否已去？但我认为C++是那种曾经从严冬中复苏过来的技术，所以我认为，嗯，我认为，你知道，2000年到2010年对C++来说确实是一段艰难的时期，但后来我们迎来了文艺复兴，也许这次我们会迎来启蒙运动。你知道，我认为这可能是C++的另一个黑暗时代周期。某些掌权者肯定会加速事情的发展。是的。
I think there is a question of the speed at which the reform comes and does it come fast enough to truly save the language? And by the time we make the improvements that we need to is it is the writing already on the wall but i think that c++ is the sort of technology that has come back from a winter before so i i think that um i i think that that there's you know the the the 2000 to 2010 was a real rough time for c++ um but then we had a renaissance and you know maybe maybe we'll have an enlightenment this time um you know i i think that uh that it could be another dark days cycle for c++ certain Certain people in charge could certainly accelerate things. Yeah.
不过我认为你可能忽略了部分问题，即这种向所谓的下一代的权力交接。我认识下一代中的一些人，他们和老一辈是一样的。他们属于，他们属于老一辈。
I think that a part of the problem though that you're potentially missing is that this passing of the torch to the next quote-unquote, you know, generation. I know some of the folks in that next generation and they have the same they're of the old guard. They're in the, they're, they're of the old guard.
他们身处新一代，但他们属于老一辈。我只是觉得，取决于谁，你知道，我不认为一旦权杖交接，我们就一定会专注于新的方向以及如何转型，这是一个板上钉钉的事情。我认为存在这样一种可能性：你交出了权杖，但什么都没有改变。我确实认为，下一代领导层几乎普遍拥有一个共同点，那就是他们对多元化和包容性的看法，这是社区面临的一个重大的非技术挑战。
They're in the new generation, but they're of the old guard. And I just, I think depending on who, you know, I don't think it's a, a, a sure thing that once this torch gets passed, that we are now focused on a new direction and how to pivot. I think that there's a possibility that you pass the torch and nothing changes. I do think that the passing of the torch, one thing that the next generation of leadership almost universally has in common is the outlook on diversity and inclusion, which is a major non-technical challenge that the community faces.
真的吗？我们要把另一个名字消音。你觉得他在那个行列里吗？是的，我也这么觉得。我们显然会剪掉所有这些，因为这不能播。好吧。你可能刚刚听到一些花栗鼠的声音，或者我不知道。也许我必须把它全部剪掉以防万一，因为如果有人能把它放慢速度，弄清楚我们到底在说什么，那是什么——你管那叫什么？
Really? We're going to bleep out another name. What about you think he's in that boat? Yes, I think so. We're going to cut all this obviously because it can't go in. All right. You probably just heard some chipmunk voices or I don't know. Maybe I got to cut it all out just in case because if someone could slow it down and get what we were actually saying, that's a – what do you call that?
内行黑话，诸如此类。也许我们会开办一个付费播客，但我从来、从来不想这么做。因为我永远不想把我的内容放在付费墙后面，但我们也可以这样做：如果你想，如果你想每个月付给我一百万美元，我会把所有的内幕八卦都告诉你。你知道吗？我们会开个OnlyFans。哦，对。一个专门用来聊内行黑话的OnlyFans。无论如何，各位，让我们知道你们的想法。C++是在消亡还是正在日落西山？我真希望你没说过这话，因为肯定会有很多人让我们知道他们的想法。
Inside baseball something, something. Maybe we'll start a premium podcast, which I never, I never want to do. Cause I never want to put my content behind money paywall, but we could just do like, if you, if you want, if you want to pay me a hundred dollars a month, I will give you all the inside gossip. You know what? We'll, we'll start an only, we'll start an only fans. Oh Oh, yeah. An OnlyFans where we just talk about inside baseball. Anyways, folks, let us know what you think. Is C++ dying slash sunsetting into the land? I wish you hadn't said that because there are definitely going to be a lot of people who are going to let us know what they think.
我肯定会从这一集中得到很多反对意见。没关系。老实说。如果你喜欢我所说的话，我的名字叫布莱斯·霍尔巴格（Bryce Adelstein Lelbach），好了，第150期到此结束。我们可能会做一些特别的事情。我们是，我知道我们不能证实那个想法，但我想我们肯定会想办法做一个
And I'm definitely going to get a lot of blowback from this episode. It's fine. Honestly. definitely going to get a lot of blowback from this episode it's fine honestly so if you if you have if you if you liked things that i said my name is bryce the whole bag and if you all right that's a wrap for episode 150 we might be doing a couple special things we are i know we can't confirm the one idea, but I think we definitely are going to figure out how to do either a
Twitter空间（Twitter Spaces），或者某种Discord或YouTube直播，我们在那里录制一集，让大家有机会互动并进行AMA（问答）。我们可能不会让你有权对着麦克风实时提问，但我们会某种形式的问答参与。
Twitter spaces or some kind of Discord or YouTube live stream where we record an episode and give folks the ability to interact and do an AMA. We might not have you have the ability to talk into a mic and ask us live, but we will have some kind of, you know, question and answer participation.
我想我们会尝试在Twitter上做，通过Twitter Spaces，在与那些想要收听和互动的人进行互动方面取得了一定程度的成功。我们还筹备了其他几项工作。三周年纪念日快到了。我们得想办法做点特别的事情。是的，我们会说祝你有美好的一天。是的，请务必查看你的播客应用中的shownotes，或者访问ADpthepodcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何链接，以及指向GitHub讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下评论、想法和感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高质量，这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语，
I think we're I think we'll try and do it on Twitter, Twitter spaces and having a modicum of success in interacting with folks that want to listen and interact. And we've got a couple other things lined up. We're coming up on the three year anniversary. We got to figure out to do something special. And yeah, we'll say have a good day. Yeah. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADpthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a github discussion where you can leave comments thoughts and questions thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast it's not the tagline
我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的口号是带有信息点缀的混乱。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。